[Music]
this is apple's lightning charger cable
and it hasn't changed in 10 years but
the eu wants apple to change that and
adopt a more universal cable enter usbc
apple has been fighting it let's talk
about why that is and how the company's
going about it
usbc is a free open standard supported
by a network of more than 700 companies
it's even supported by apple then why is
apple the only company that hasn't added
it to its smartphones
the company switched from this 30-pin
connector to lightning in 2012. at the
time lightning was groundbreaking but as
the years went on a shift happened
lightning started to fade as most new
ipads and all of apple's new macs got
usbc ports now just a couple of apple
products still have lightning ports and
most importantly iphones apple's most
popular product
the eu argues that it's both expensive
and inconvenient for consumers to have
to carry multiple charges for multiple
devices and so now policymakers are
proposing a shift one that would require
iphone sold in europe to have a usbc
port that legislation if passed this
year would give companies two years to
make the change for apple to meet that
deadline the company would already need
to be working on a usbc iphone or figure
out another way out now there is a
precedent for this situation in 2009
tech companies and the eu reached a
voluntary agreement and because of that
micro usbs became a lot more common in
2009 we had more than 30
3-0 charging solutions currently we have
only three main
possibilities in 2019 the eu said that
removing all of these exclusive chargers
would save around 13 000 tons of
electronic waste per year electronic
waste is still one of the fastest
growing waste streams which makes this
type of base prevention particularly
important so why is apple fighting all
of this anyway analysts tell me it comes
down to three main things money control
and design apple makes money from all
the lightning tables it sells and it
also makes money on non-apple products
made by third parties that go through
its made for iphone program
and then there's control without the
lightning cable apple doesn't have as
much control over its ecosystem apple
learned the hard way with the 30 pin
when they discontinued that that ended
up causing some angst with the apple
users they moved too quickly away from
that so apple wants to not uh go too
fast and lastly experts tell me that the
lightning port allows apple to make
slimmer phones with a more compact
opening it's smaller which gives them
more flexibility to design other things
into the iphone and even though it may
seem like not a big piece of it uh every
little piece counts when it comes to
miniaturizing what's in the phone apple
said in a statement we remain concerned
that strict regulation mandating just
one type of connector stifles innovation
rather than encouraging it which in turn
will harm consumers in europe and around
the world but what happens if the eu
actually succeeds clearly switching an
iphone from one charging standard to
another isn't impossible this college
student studying robotics even did it
this is it people the world's first usbc
iphone
but watch this
apple has another option for getting
around usbc every single iphone since
the iphone 8 supports qi wireless
charging if apple created iphones that
didn't have a single port but supported
wireless charging the company would get
around the eu's plans but today there's
an engineering problem you're getting
speed charges that are five ten times
longer when you compare to the faster
charging uh cables today
if the eu has its way apple might have
to create a specialized iphone just for
europe or change all of its smartphones
globally but frankly i'd be happy to not
have to carry around so many cables to
charge my devices or have to try to
figure out which end of the cable goes
where if you want to find out more about
what apple or other smartphone makers
are working on subscribe to my channel
and let me know in the comments section
what you think i should look into next
you